[Musique]
je crois au coup de foudre a pas de
vraiment juste des mots inventer une
relation
j'adore si simple si agréable c'est
ainsi que notre histoire commence
banques
[Musique]
je crois qui me plaît en fait c'est
abusé c'est parfait
[Musique]
je vais continuer à être le mec parfait
qui finira par comprendre que je ne suis
pas une option je suis le bon l'amour
c'est compliqué je peux te parler
sérieusement tu choisis très mal tes
amis
il faut savoir se protéger
elle a de la chance que je sois là beck
s'est rarement ce qui est mieux pour
elle parfois ça me fait peur d'aimer à
ce point à une personne dont je sais
qu'elle n'est même pas
il faut que je sache qui tu es vraiment
je me suis déjà trompé sur les gens dans
le passé
[Musique]
est ce que tu me suis
je vois clair trop cher je ne la
laisserai pas se mettre en travers de
nos
des fois on pourrait presque croire qu
était pas net
qu'est devenu dingue
honnêtement bec tu as de la chance que
je sois là
toutes les relations leurs obstacles à
surmonter
wei